Three decades of regret? Eddie Murphy
turned down playing a different Eddie
in one of Disney's greatest cult classics.
Why? He thought the movie was just too weird.
"Hey! Eddie, take it easy, will ya? Please, Eddie!
Don't throw me out, you're making a big mistake!"
Eddie Murphy is as iconic as his movies. The
actor and comedian is legendary thanks to films
like "Coming to America," "Beverly Hills Cop,"
and "Shrek." But even though Murphy has played
some of the most recognizable roles in Hollywood,
he's also had the bad luck of playing some of the
worst. The actor has been nominated for nine
Razzie awards, and managed to take home three,
thanks in part to the likes of "Norbit"
and "The Adventures of Pluto Nash."
Those flops didn't exactly help his career,
but thanks to "Coming to America 2" and
2019's "Dolemite Is My Name," the actor
has once again entered the limelight.
"What a totally unexpected surprise."
It's almost hard to believe the number of
recognizable roles the actor has to his name,
but one more could've been added to that list.
What movie does Murphy still regret
turning down after all these years?
You might be surprised to learn that it was none
other than the groundbreaking "Who Framed Roger
Rabbit." Released in 1988, "Who Framed Roger
Rabbit" is a bold film that seamlessly blends
live-action and animation into an engaging story
that still holds up against modern standards.
The movie stars Bob Hoskins as Eddie Valiant, a
private detective who gets drawn into a murder
investigation involving Roger Rabbit. The movie
was an unmitigated success -- it currently holds
a 97% on Rotten Tomatoes and earned over $154
million domestically against a $70 million budget.
"So tell me, Eddie, is that a rabbit in your
pocket or are you just happy to see me?"
While speaking with Jimmy Fallon in
late 2019, Eddie Murphy said that he
was offered the starring role of Eddie
Valiant. He passed on the film because
the concept was so unusual that he didn't
think it had any chance of being a success.
"And I was like, what? Animation and
people? That sounds like bulls--- to me. And
now every time I see it, I feel like an idiot."
With Murphy in the lead role, "Who Framed Roger
Rabbit would've undoubtedly been a very different
movie than the one we know now. But that's just
the way the business goes. Hollywood is filled
with countless "What if" stories. Actors turn
down roles, or back out for various reasons.
And as it turns out, Murphy more than
has his fair share of these stories.
In addition to missing out on "Who Framed Roger
Rabbit," Murphy most notably lost the chance to
star in 1984's "Ghostbusters." Murphy could've
played Winston, but he instead opted to star
in "Beverly Hills Cop." It proved to be a
fruitful move; rather than feature as one
person in an ensemble, Murphy had the chance to
lead a film that went on to spawn two sequels.
But that wasn't necessarily a strategic decision
on Murphy's part. The actor claimed in
an interview with Extra in 2003 that,
like "Roger Rabbit," he also turned down
"Ghostbusters" because he didn't see the
premise having any chance of success. As he put
it at the time, quote, "This sounds like a crock."
The actor also passed on starring
as Detective Carter in the hit
action-comedy "Rush Hour" to instead
star in the widely forgotten "Holy Man."
"I guess that's a good way to go."
"Rush Hour" would spawn several sequels, while
"Holy Man" was a box office and critical bomb.
In an interview with Extra, Murphy dished on the
process with his usual sense of humor, saying:
"It's funny when I think of it now. It was like,
'You can go jump all over California
with Jackie Chan or go to Miami and
wear a robe for three months.' I went
to Miami, and you see the results."
Funnily enough, even though Murphy turned down
"Rush Hour," he actually inspired the entire film,
according to an interview the eventual "Rush Hour"
star, Chris Tucker, gave to East Coast Radio.
"When Eddie Murphy did
Beverly Hills Cop, that's my
Rush Hour. That's how Rush Hour came about,
because of Eddie Murphy's Beverly Hills Cop."
But despite missing out on all these
blockbuster movies, Murphy has still
only claimed to regret turning down
"Who Framed Roger Rabbit." Fortunately,
thanks to his recent resurgence, Murphy
isn't hurting for good roles these days.
All these years later, it's
safe to say he's still got it.
"Yeah, you still got it."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.